what really breaks my heart is how stuck
people are there are things you can do
to change your life for the better and
so let me give you the secret Mel
Robbins one of the most trusted experts
on confidence and motivation her unique
brand of raw and relatable advice has
made her one of the most sought after
speakers in the world don't rely on
motivation motivation garbage because
it's not there when you need it and the
fact is if it were easy to develop great
habits or change your mindset everybody
would have their dreams come true it is
very difficult to change because we are
hardwired to spot patterns that seem
similar and to repeat them there's also
this voice that is talking to you all
the time going boy you really suck and
you blew that and my God you're never
going to amount to anything constantly
telling you what you think about
yourself and of course what you think
about yourself then drives the things
that you do but luckily there's two ways
around it one is to that absolutely
works let them let them let them let
them the let them theory is based on a
simple truth the fastest way to take
control of your life is to stop
controlling everyone around you that
opinion is usually driven by your
insecurity controlling nature your
anxiety and it is ruining your
relationships but when you say let them
something really interesting happens you
will
notice it's absolutely
life-changing you
will
at this time of year everybody is
thinking about changes that they want to
make in their life but it's incredibly
hard to become a new person when your
circumstances stay the same in this
episode me and Mel go on a journey to
figure out how you listening to this at
home can change your life we go through
the science we go through the proven
strategies and we go through some of the
mindset alterations we all need to make
going into next year if we want to stand
the chance of closing the gap on our
potential and when I say potential I'm
not talking about success alone I'm
talking about happiness and I'm talking
about health things that I think
everybody that listens to this podcast
cares so deeply about and there's one
thing that Mel says this idea of the let
them Theory which sounds so
simple but I honestly think could change
your life whether it's in your
relationships at work with your partner
or when someone cuts you off in traffic
this let them theory for me since Mel
told me about it has significantly
improved my life I can't wait for you to
listen to this episode Mel is just the
best and before this episode starts I
want to make a deal with you about 58%
of you that watch this podcast
frequently haven't yet hit the Subscribe
button if you enjoy what we do here
here's the deal that I want to make with
you if you hit that subscribe button I
promise you that we will keep making the
show better better in every single way
and we have huge plans to turn this into
more of a documentary style conversation
where we work incredibly hard to bring
in footage of the things we're talking
about to give you greater context and
greater meaning so if you hit the
Subscribe button I promise you that we
will deliver an even greater version of
this show I hope you choose to come
along on this journey enjoy this
[Music]
episode
Mel I'm thinking about the 45-year-old
Taxi Driver that's her dad I'm thinking
about Judith who has an idea for a
handbag business she wants to start but
she's 56 years old and maybe Society has
convinced her that she can't change now
she can't pivot away from where she is
I'm also thinking about the 27y old
medical graduate who became a dentist
because their immigrant mother told them
that was success and happiness and they
never listened to the voice inside of
them those people that are in those
situations where they feel like they've
gone so far down a
path how does one turn back move forward
I mean I don't even know what Direction
You Don't Turn back okay well because
here's the thing first of all I'm 55 and
I did not even get started in the
podcast business until I was 54 years
old and so I personally feel that my
life and the business that I've built
and the example that I set every single
day is evidence that you can decide at
any age that you are going to Pivot and
turn in a New Direction and One metaphor
that has helped me Stephen A Lot in my
life is I think
about life as one long road trip and
that that I know it sounds super cheesy
but just bear with me for a minute if
you think about every single year of
your life as a mile marker
and the fact that we all start at zero
we all end at some
point when you think about your life as
a road trip and you're the driver that
means it's about navigating where you go
next and at any single moment you can
pull over stop the damn car like if you
feel lost if you feel turned around if
you have hit a dead end do not find your
way by continuing to drive in circles
stop for a second a ESS where you are
tune back into the navigation system
that is inside you and you can turn your
life in a New Direction you do it over
and over and over again in business you
have this Natural Curiosity this natural
drive if your instincts tell you to go
you point towards it I have
that but for everybody that's listening
or watching us who feels like you don't
ever have that moment where your
intuition tells you it's that way let me
give you the secret to how to make your
next big move and the secret is
this pay attention to what sucks in your
life because there are positive
navigational signals and there are
negative ones and when it comes to my
life Stephen you seem to have able to
tap into the positive I have a much
greater like I don't know I'm I'm more
deeply connected to the negative [__]
the jealousy
frustration um feeling anger anytime
those emotions come up in my body it's
just a directional signal from deep
inside of you telling you you're about
you're you're supposed to Pivot like do
not head in the same direction do not do
not keep going the same speed make a
change
so I hear you say that we can pull over
on the side of the road at any moment in
our life but I guess some people who are
listening to that will think well I
can't stop because I've got a mortgage
to pay I've got bills to pay I've got
responsibilities I I have no time to
even think about that and also there's
this other group of people who maybe
feel the frustration and the jealousy
and the the rage that kind of drives you
and me to some
degree but for some reason even though
they know every fiber in their body
knows that this is not the situation for
them this is the wrong relationship
wrong job wrong City wrong friendship
group they still for some reason just
can't take that step into
uncertainty uhhuh which is I think most
people probably yes I I I almost believe
that people don't
have a signal problem I they we all feel
the same signal but they have a problem
with acting on the signal because
correct so I personally believe that we
are all born the second you come out and
into this world you are hardwired with
this natural intelligence that is your
own personal inner compass and that it
is tuned into what is unique to you it
is constantly programmed by the
experiences of your life but it is
always signaling toward what is uniquely
aligned for you if you just accept the
premise that we are energetic human
beings that we give off energy we
receive energy we've all had the
experience where walk into a like a
retail store and all of a sudden
something feels off that is the compass
I'm talking about signaling to you based
on your experience based on your DNA
based on the generational wisdom that is
passed down through your ancestors that
there is something there for you to pay
attention to the problem is not what
your inner Compass is telling you and
the problem is that you won't listen to
it and I can prove it because if you
have somebody that comes up to you and
says oh man I've been in this
relationship and that relationship and
the other thing and I'm just unlucky in
love and I can't trust myself and I
don't da da da da da da da da I always
say to somebody
stop it's not that you can't trust
yourself because your instincts have
always been right I want you to go back
through the five or six horrible
relationships that you just had and I
want you to look backwards and the
fastest way to do this is look back
through your photos and that'll take you
back on the timeline and that'll remind
you of all this stuff and I want you to
look at your face and I want you to just
be honest with yourself when did you
know this wasn't working and you will
always have somebody admit that they
knew seven years before the divorce they
knew a year before the breakup they knew
before they even hooked up with the
person the first time that this was
probably not the right thing because it
felt a little off but it was confusing
because you know you've got all the like
Rush of the adrenaline and the
attraction and all the hormones and all
that stuff but deep down inside if you
got really quiet you knew that this was
not the right decision for you and so
the issue isn't the accuracy of your
inner wisdom the issue is your courage
and following it because following your
inner wisdom and making decisions that
are aligned with what you are meant to
do in your life the kind of people
you're supposed to be with right now the
kind of support that you need the things
that are interesting to you it always
requires you to do something different
than what you're doing now the problem
is if it requires you to do something
new what's also going to happen is
you're going to have a fear response and
we mistake those moments of change or
those moments where you're going to try
something new the moments of
vulnerability the moments where you're
going to risk a little the moments that
require courage courage we mistake the
very natural response to change which is
a little moment of feeling alarmed with
your intuition being wrong and so one
way that you can tell the difference is
the feeling of the decision if the
decision is the right decision in terms
of a decision that is aligned with who
you are and your soul and your DNA and
just this deep wisdom inside you even if
it's scary you will feel a sense of
expansion you will feel like something
is growing that there is
possibility even though you're nervous
about it even though you're not quite
sure where you're going to go if the
decision is wrong when you get quiet and
you drop in you will feel a sense of
shrinking you'll feel constrained you'll
feel a little depleted in your energy
and we often mistake that kind of
nervousness that you feel before you
make a decision to quit your job or a
decision you know what I'm gonna get Ser
about serious about my finances I'm GNA
stop going out to the bar on the
weekends and and I'm gonna commit to
listening to this podcast two hours
every weekend to start learning and
start mastering skills and to literally
put these things that I want first now
on Friday night when your buddies
calling like Hey we're going down to the
pub you want to
come when you are about to say
no you're going to feel that rise up
because you've never done this before
you always go and you know you're going
to get blowb but if you get really quiet
and you drop in and you ask yourself
okay if I were to go to the bar tonight
does that feel like something
expansive or does that feel like
something that's shrinking me a little
bit and you'll know the right answer for
you and that's a tool that I have used
over and over and and over again in my
life to know what to do it doesn't
answer
how it doesn't answer when it answers
what there's a quote I heard many years
ago I think almost a decade ago which
stayed with me because I tried to
understand why sometimes it seems like
people need a little bit more pain
before they make a change and the quote
is change happens when the pain of
staying the same becomes greater than
the pain of making a change
and I sometimes this sounds like a crazy
thing to say but I sometimes see people
in certain situations where they're
debating making a change or getting that
gym membership or breaking out of a
cycle that they've has kept them trapped
in a situation which has made made them
unhappy and it appears that they just
need a little bit more pain what you're
talking about is a fundamental fact and
that is you cannot change another person
people only change when they're ready to
change and if what it requires s is more
pain or hitting a rock bottom or the
stakes becoming so
high that somebody sees the cost of
continuing to self-sabotage or to go on
the path that they're going
down that for some people is the only
moment in time where they see that they
want things to be different and
you can't want somebody's sobriety or
their healing or their Financial Freedom
more than they do because at the very
bottom we learn I guess we learned two
things as you said there the cost of
continuing but also the reward of change
is is never greater when you're at the
very bottom of the mountain it's like
the cost of continuing down here plus
also the reward of me climbing that
mountain are at maximum yeah and look
you know we're having an intellectual
conversation and you know the fact is
it's really hard to change yeah if it
were easy to develop great habits or
change your mindset and it could happen
like that everybody would have six-pack
abs everybody would have four companies
like you do everybody would have a hit
podcast everybody would have their
dreams come true and it is very
difficult to change because we are
hardwired to spot patterns that seem
similar and to repeat them and so I do
think it's important to say that if
you're struggling if you're frustrated
with yourself if you're at that point
where you're so sick of yourself and
your excuses I've been there step's been
there this is a normal part of the human
experience and at some point either the
pain is going to get big enough or
you're going to bump into somebody's
story somewhere on this planet who has
been in the position that you're in
right now facing the stuff that you're
facing right now and there is something
about their story at this exact moment
in time that will ignite something in
you that is missing and what is missing
in you right now is Hope because when
you're stuck and when you are on a Down
Road spiral whether it's just in your
own head or it's in self-destructive
Behavior the thing that's missing in
your life is hope you don't believe
right now that anything is going to make
a difference and so until you get to the
point where you just hate what you're
doing so much that it's worth
trying or you have somebody crack open a
door and just a little light comes in
and you have this moment where you go
well what
if what if this is the time sobriety
sticks what if I go to therapy and I
actually do change the way that I think
what if I could recover from this
narcissistic abuse that I've you know
been kind of struggling with after that
relationship or that marriage what if I
could get out of debt if that person did
maybe I could do it and without either
hope or that kind of rock bottom moment
I don't think you're going to change can
you tell the difference between someone
who is likely to change and someone who
isn't because there must be so many
people that message you and they present
a facade as if they have had that
realization and they're about to change
M I'm about to start that business thank
than you so much for everything you've
done and you look in their eyes and you
go and you go I don't believe a word he
was saying and then I'll tell you it's
it's that's a that's an energy thing I
mean you're somebody who invests in a
lot of people and I would imagine that
in addition to looking at the business
model you're actually looking at the
person and talk is
cheap like the kind of people that are
actually going to change will thank you
for the hope and thank you for a
specific piece of advice and then they
are moving so fast out that door because
they realize that change doesn't happen
overnight it doesn't happen with one
Insight it is tedious it is painful it
is lonely because it is a game of just
moving the ball down the field Inch by
Inch by Inch it's not glamorous it's
lonely as you start changing everything
around you starts changing people around
you like it just it's not even fun in
the beginning and so you'd either have
to have an incredible amount of Hope or
a ridiculous amount of inspiration and
delusion or you have to be in so much
pain that the alternative to continuing
this pain that you're in is to try
something different because it's the
only thing that might be slightly less
painful than what you're doing you get
to that point where you know I call it
the [__] it like this is bad so [__] it
let's try something else like I you know
and so I I I really believe that and I I
think people you can't tell who's going
to change because it's a it's a long
game is there anything that breaks your
heart about what you do for all the
upsides of it for oh my God yes
yeah what really breaks my heart is how
stuck people
are and that there are things you can do
to change your life for the better and
if you don't have
hope and you don't have this
breakthrough where you have for just a
millisecond this Insight where you go
well what if things did work
out if you don't have that moment most
people stay so stuck in
resignation and actually that's one of
the things that really um I'm so so
curious about with you because I like
you talk to so many people and have so
many people writing in and um the number
of people that are living their life at
40 or 50 or 60 and they are defined by
the trauma that happened in their
childhood and that's not to say that the
trauma wasn't profound or wasn't
impactful and having experienced
childhood trauma of my own that I didn't
discover until later in life I I I I
find it so
sad that so many people just don't
know that they're stuck in patterns of
abuse or patterns of thinking that they
can change and if you're not aware that
you're stuck in something there's no way
you can change it and so it makes me
extremely sad that there are um so many
people that are not aware of how much
better and how much more present and how
much more joy they could experience in
their life is much of that identity like
the identity the stories the stories we
tell ourselves about oursel sort of
circulates around us it becomes this
instruction manual for everything we do
believe and think of ourselves and that
is ultimately like the story of Steven
Bartlett that I have authored based on
everything I interpreted that happened
in my life things happen I write a new
line into myself self story about who
Steve B is because of that and use that
as my instruction manual for forward
sort of facing Behavior I think one of
the most interesting experts to talk to
about that topic is I think his first
name is Paul Dr Paul Ki from Stanford I
know his his last name is Dr Ki um but I
just interviewed him for our podcast and
his work is all on the inner voice and
the subconscious and that there is this
narrative that you have that you may not
even be aware is talking to you all the
time and when you start to turn toward
what that self-critic is saying you know
you're never good enough why'd you screw
that up and you start to examine what
it's telling you it would be as if I was
walking behind you Stephen all day long
going boy you really suck and you blew
that and my God you're never going to
amount to anything and you're going to
be alone and you're going to do this and
it's not and and we do it to ourselves
and so yes your selft talk which is
probably buried somewhere very deep this
is not my area of expertise in terms of
Psychiatry or Neuroscience but we just
interviewed him and it was fascinating
is informing what you think about
yourself and of course what you think
about yourself then drives the things
that you do is it thought driven or
behavior driven is it nervous system
driven first is it subconscious driven
first here's what I know I know that
until you make a DEC decision that you
no longer want to feel how you feel or
you no longer want to think the way that
you think or you no longer want to have
the kind of results or no results that
you have until you make that decision
that you know what I know I don't feel
great I know I doubt myself I know I've
had a lot of bad things happen I know
there's a lot that I regret but damn it
with the time that I have left in my
life I really want to start to enjoy
myself I want to take better care of
myself I want to feel happy you don't
even have to believe you deserve it yet
you can just want it you've got to start
there you've got to start with wanting
something better for yourself and then I
personally think the most important
thing is to start
acting like the person who has the
things that you want right now even
though you don't feel like it and the
reason why I personally prefer to hack
this change of going okay I want to um
like here's here's something that I am
working on right now so I'm 55 years old
I'm in the middle of menopause it's a
complete Nightmare and uh I feel as out
of control with my body as I did when I
was pregnant with one of our three kids
like everything's changing it's really
confusing to figure out what's going on
the um I could go on and on and on about
this as as somebody who's in the middle
of it trying to figure out what to do
around my changing hormones and how to
get better control of my health and so
what do I do I feel a little discouraged
right now I don't really know what to do
I just know I don't like how my body is
feeling and how it's changing and so I
make a decision and a commitment to
myself that I want to feel better I want
to understand this and so that decision
is super important because without
deciding that I want to do something I'm
not doing anything
and then I start to study all of the
experts and what people have to say
about this topic of hormone balance and
gut health and Women's Health and how to
uh regulate your hormones naturally and
what to like there's just so much
information out there and then I make a
decision okay well what are the two or
three things that I'm going to do and
then I start doing it and I wake up
every day and I do those things even if
I don't feel like it even if my selft
talk is pretty poor and here's what
happens over time for me personally is
if I see myself taking actions
consistent with somebody who exercises
or somebody who is taking care of her
Hormone Health or somebody who uh is not
drinking or somebody who is writing a
book if I see myself taking those
actions it changes the way that I look
at myself the action first approach is
what I personally believe in because I
think it works faster everybody that
hears you saying that and everybody who
sees people be disciplined in that way
the illusion is that they're just
profoundly motivated oh my God no no I I
think motivation is garbage I mean I um
and I always thought that was funny
given that
I was a motivational speaker for a long
time and here I think it's garbage and
the reason why I think motivation is
garbage is because it's not there when
you need
it and I don't rely on
motivation I do not expect to feel
motivated I do not expect to feel like
doing things and I make myself do them
that does not mean by the way that I
have great willpower that does not mean
that I consider myself to be a
disciplined person that means that I
understand the
biology of how most human beings work
and the biology of how most human beings
work is that you feel a sensation in
your body so let's just take an example
like getting out of bed okay the you set
the alarm the night before I know you
don't but most normal human beings set
the alarm the night before and when the
alarm goes
off you're going to get out of bed right
I mean that's how it's supposed to work
because when you set the alarm the night
before you're setting it for a time
where you're basically supposed to get
up so you are making a promise to your
future self in the morning that you're
going to get out of bed well what
happens all kinds of things happen you
go to bed the alarm rings and the first
thing that you feel is a sensation and
for me the Sensation that I always feel
in my body is something that I would
call I don't know if it's the cortisol I
I don't know if it's partying I don't
know if it's menopause I don't know if
it's the fact that I have a fabulous bed
and my husband's next to me and I don't
want to get out of bed I don't know if
it's the fact that it I live in southern
Vermont and it's freezing like I don't
know but the first sensation
is then perception so sensation
perception then feeling then thought
then action that is the biological chain
of events that happens in a
nanc and I know that this is what's
happening so I have the
feeling I then have the perception
happen which is I look around it's dark
Chris is next to me I then have an
emotion about it overwhelm frustration
like you know usually something negative
then I have a thought which is I don't
want to get out of
bed and that for years would trigger the
action I would take and what most of us
I certainly didn't understand that
sensation perception feeling or emotion
thinking and then action is the chain of
events that is how you're
hardwired this is how it works body keep
like this is how it works it wasn't
until I understood that holy cow if I
don't reverse the
chain my sensation my perception my
emotions about things and my thinking
all four or five of those things
actually precede what action I take and
I'm not in control of what I'm doing my
emotions and my Sensations and my trauma
and like all of the stuff that has been
running on like autop forever that is
controlling who Mel Robbins is and at
some point if that's working for you
fantastic if there's an area of your
life that you're not happy in then you
got to reverse the order or I guess or
and you can go to therapy for months and
months and months and do the work and
slowly but surely you will change the
way that you think which also helps but
I find that understanding that that is
the chain of events and for those of us
that have any kind of childhood
trauma where sensation is the first
thing that you feel that then triggers
that whole pathway or you have any kind
of anxiety again sensation of the alarm
that then triggers a whole pathway of
action and
reaction this is one of the reasons why
you feel out of control it's because the
sensation and the wiring in your body is
actually triggering this chain reaction
and you don't even realize it it's why
avoiding things or freezing has become
your default response to everything
because every sensation triggers the
exact same thing which leads to an
action of avoidance and the way around
that is to flip that and start with
making taking better actions regardless
of how you feel there's two ways around
it one is to work with a licensed
therapist who can help you do the deeper
work
of understanding yourself and
understanding your default thinking
patterns and doing the work to challenge
those assumptions and change the way
that you
think that absolutely works if you will
commit to the process of doing
it the second way and you can do these
together certainly how I did it is to
look at your behaviors and understand
that there is this chain of this there
is this order that happens in your body
and reverse it take a behavior first
approach what if if you want to get in
better shape what does somebody do who
is in the kind of shape that you want to
be in ask yourself what the behavior is
because I'll tell you the reason why
you're not taking those behaviors is
because this chain of events in your
body from Sensation to perception to
feeling and emotion to thinking is
constantly telling you I don't feel like
it I don't want to it's not going to
work anyway I'm GNA eat that thing yeah
I'm GNA eat that thing I'll do it
tomorrow and you can reverse it it's
funny because everyone knows how I well
I believe I believe 99% of people know
how they should behave to become the
person they want to become they know
they probably shouldn't have that I
don't know bowl of ice cream at 2: a.m.
in the morning right they know that they
probably should get up in the morning
and run for 5 kilometers they know they
probably should check in with their
friends and family they probably etc etc
etc um but here's the thing you're not
making your behavior decisions with your
brain you're making them with the
sensation in your body if you don't feel
like doing it you don't do it see before
it even gets up here you feel it in here
and this was the thing that was
revelatory for me is like oh my God like
my emotions drive my entire life and
that's why I feel out of control and
that's why I'm frustrated with myself
and that's why I can talk till I'm blue
in the face about what I need to do and
what I should do and what this and what
that but when push comes to shove if I
don't feel like doing it where I'm
scared or I'm this or I'm that I don't
do it that means my emotions and the
sensations of my body and the patterns
that have been hardwired for a long time
and the coping mechanisms that just run
on autopilot that's what's driving you
it's not up here so we've broken our
cycle who has well I don't know I I I
dude I wake up every I still I know all
this and this is the other like I think
is a really important thing for you to
hear not you Stephen but everybody
watching and listening to us and that is
that I I personally feel it's important
to understand that you may never like
the things you need to do and you can
still do
them like I I I will never like getting
out of
bed and I still get out of bed when the
alarm rings I don't like emptying the
dishwasher and I still do it I don't
like exercising I still do it I don't
like eating healthy a lot of the times I
still do it I don't
like taking a breath and centering
myself
when I really when I just scream at my
husband and I still do it because I let
my
emotions and my anxiety and my trauma
responses and my fears run my life for
far too long and I would rather be in
the
daily I don't know if you call it a
battle or you just call it I'm just in a
daily dance with myself
to constantly come back
to alignment and peace and showing up is
the kind of person that I want to be
rather than how I may feel in the
moment one of the things I did want to
speak to you about is about how we know
what we want and how we set set goals
again we're we're in that part of the
year now where everybody's thinking you
know we've talked a little bit about how
one changes themselves but then even
knowing what direction to aim at is a
whole challenge in of itself how does
one know at 30 years old in my
life what
real goals I should be aiming at cuz
part of the concern I've had is I wonder
if I'm driven or being dragged and what
do you think don't know I don't really
know the difference [__] you know no I
don't you are the most driven person I
know why why I don't know I'm gonna ask
you just give me this part for my
interview well this is something why are
you the most person I know why are you
me yeah um well I think I was outrunning
something for a very long time sounds
like being dragged is it I I genuinely
have sat here with hundreds of people
and every single time they explain their
motivation to me I go sounds like you're
being dragged by shame your father's
opinion of you insecurity whatever like
the AR that's a negative way to say it I
mean I feel like that's why people don't
like it they sound powerless they sound
like they're attached to the back of the
L and it's flying down the motorway well
if you recognize that's what it is you
suddenly become powerful yeah and you
can drive yes yeah so for me if I put it
through the lens of like the bad things
that happened it would probably be
um uh just like outrunning like a
psychiatrist once said to me it's very
interesting to me that when this you
know incident happened in the fourth
grade and this kid climbed on top of you
while you were sleeping you are in a
state when you're sleeping where you are
completely supposedly
safe and so I'm not sure Mel your
nervous system ever reset back to a
place of feeling safe and then the
hypervigilance of having you know a care
caregiver who was always kind of very
erratic with their personality also made
me feel always on the Move always on the
Move always on the move you know if
you're on the move nobody can catch you
and and so slowing down if you put it in
that context becomes unsafe
right however if you look at a lot of
our experiences growing up most of us
get a lot of positive attention when we
achieve and so we become whether you
want to say driven or dragged it's
probably just a matter of whether or not
you're in control of it a lot of us are
driven by the desire to want to feel
seen the desire to feel loved the desire
to to get the accolades which is why so
many of us feel driven to achieve
because it's tied into a sense of
self-worth it's tied into a sense of uh
being loved being
seen for me um I think I was probably to
use your words dragged since I wasn't in
control of it um but more and more I
feel profoundly driven I often think
people need to be dragged to to a place
where they realize that it's failed them
that something has failed them for them
to then take stock and decide to become
a little bit more intentional and to
take hold of the steering wheel because
in my situation I was 100% dragged to
thinking that I needed a million pounds
a six-pack a girlfriend and a ranger
over Sport and then upon getting those
things it was like almost a bit of an
existential crisis like what the [__] am
I doing here right what failed me and
why did I come to this part and then in
that moment I could really take stock of
what my own intrinsic drivers were and
then do things a little bit more
intentionally um and aligned with
disassociated from the thought that any
of these things would validate me at
some deeper level I think a lot of
this that we're talking about isn't
conscious decisions that anybody's
making that there is so much
conditioning and programming that
happens that we are unaware of as we're
growing up and as we're moving through
young adulthood that you don't even
realize how much you avoid stuff or how
much you're coping by being busy busy or
you're coping by drinking too much or
you're chasing stuff because you feel a
deep sense of self-loathing and that
most of the decisions at least this is
for me were all reactions just again
like just trying to do the best that I
can but not really in control of
anything and
until I really believe this until you
can drop into your
body
and just calm down your nervous
system and not be revving that internal
engine so much but to be able to just I
I this is not a technical term I feel
like I've smoothed out my nervous
system by doing traditional talk therapy
guided MDMA therapy with my husband um
EMDR uh all of the behavioral activation
therapy which is kind of leading with a
behavior first approach and start acting
like the person you want to be let them
let them okay well I was say fascinated
by this Theory this let them Theory
which is kind of a behavioral technique
I guess would you describe it as a
behavioral Technique No No I would what
is it so the let them
theory is based on a simple
truth the fastest
way to take control of your life is to
stop controlling everyone around
you you have no idea how much time and
energy and
attention you are
wasting trying to control other people
you have no idea how much energy you are
burning through thinking about worrying
about obsessing about what other people
are doing what they're not doing what
their feeling all of which you have zero
control
over and so the let them theory is this
simple theory that I credit my daughter
with teaching
me uh that has created so much peace in
my life because like every other human
being on the planet I had no idea how
many
opinions how much frustration
expectations I had about what other
people were doing or what they should be
doing like it's just
unreal how obsessed we all are with
everybody else and what they should be
doing and what they're not doing and
when you start to use the letm
theory you will
notice it's just
unbelievable how much you need to use it
there are exceptions I mean I can
explain a lot about this I'll I'll give
give you the quick story about how I
learned it because I think it's very
helpful so it was our son's um Junior
Prom so he's a 11th grader in the states
and like most moms you know completely
obsessed about everything it's also my
son and this is his first prom and I had
had daughters so it was a totally
different circus with our daughters and
I thought that his would be drama free
because he's a guy but it actually
became more dramatic because he doesn't
say anything and so everything Stephen
was a last minute scramble right like
from getting the tux to he needed to
have these certain Stan Smith Adidas
sneakers and we had to overnight those
to the fact that he was just going to go
with his friends and then all of a
sudden he asked a date and then she
wants a Boer she doesn't want a bout
iner and then we're going to the pre and
every step of the way I had internal
opin why does
he so we get to the pre-prom photo party
that's a lot of peas and our daughter
happened to be uh home from college and
so she was there for the
weekend and all of a sudden it starts to
rain out of nowhere and by rain I mean a
hail storm it is raining sideways and I
realize none of these kids have
umbrellas none of these kids are
prepared for this and so I turned to our
son and I'm like Oak where are you guys
going for dinner and he's like well I
don't know and I turned towards my
husband I'm like they don't have plans
for dinner what what do you mean they
didn't make a reservation for the prom
and so I start to get all worked up and
now all the other parents are like wait
you didn't make do you want me to call
the in would you guys want us to order
pizzas and the ramp up is happening and
I start to jump in and my daughter grabs
my arm and she says let them just let
them do what they want and Oak yells
over and says hey Mom I think we're
going to go to this uh Taco thing now
the taco place that they were going to
Stephen is like the size of this table
there are 20 kids it is hailing outside
they are dressed to the nines and I
could feel that volcano of control
coming up like you can't go to the taco
place you're in a tux and you got the
new sneakers and she her dress is going
to get ruined and you don't even have an
umbrella and what are you thinking and
Kendall has my arm she's like let them
if they want to go to a taco stand in
the pouring rain and ruin their dress
let them it's their prom not
yours and as she said it I started just
repeating those words even let them let
them go to the Taco Stand let them let
him ruin is shoes who
cares let let him do what he wants to do
why am I worried about what he's doing
why am I not worried about where I'm
gonna have dinner and so it was just
this moment and it immediately kind of
unhooked me and then from that point
forward I just noticed a million
situations sitting at the restaurant
that night and the waiter is busy with
other stuff and they're not not coming
to the table how does everybody feel
when that
happens let them let them be
busy let them take care of the other
table standing in line and people I
don't know what it is about the world
today but people cannot stand in lines
fidgeting and this and that and the
other thing and the person is letting in
people from that line and they're not
letting in people from this line let
them let
them and some of the like really
important topics too like if your kid
wants to drop out of school you can say
what you need to say ultimately it's
their life let them what's going on
there at the heart of that is that just
a lowering of one's expectations so that
going back to the point we said about
expectations and happiness
we alleviate the chance of
disappointment and because we're just
let we're saying fine Let It Go like
what is the very Crux of that on a
psychological level that's allowing us
to feel liberated from that stress and
need for control
what do you think it
is I think when we take on other
people's
problems um we create
expectation for them like in the case of
your son you had an expectation of what
his night would look like and where his
trainers and Tuck were going to go and
that unmet expectation is causing you
unnecessary suffering control stress
angst Vig VI vigilance and just by
saying do you know what like I wish him
well you're just cutting the cord of a
whole another stream of expectation that
you absolutely do not need you didn't
need to volunteer to make your yours and
look how much stress it created yeah and
look how much agit it created yeah so
there's so many things going on Stephen
and first of all I should also say there
are exceptions first of all you're not
just going to let your kids do whatever
they're going to do if you're a parent
because you're supposed to put the guard
rails up right MH but there is so much
controlling that we do in our lives of
other people and it is ruining your
relationships and a great example of a
way to use this is let's say that you
see that your friends are going out for
brunch this weekend they didn't invite
you happens all the time with my team
let them yeah let them yeah because
here's the thing that's really important
is it's really not about other people
see energetically you're hooking
yourself into other people because you
have an opinion about what they should
or shouldn't be doing and that opinion
is usually driven by your insecurity or
it's driven by your controlling nature
or it's driven by your anxiety or it's
driven by whatever it is that you may
have but once you get your energetic
hook into somebody else you've now just
lost control because you are now trying
to gain control of anything in your life
what your friends are doing for brunch
this weekend by focusing on them when
you say let them this is what's very
interesting it's very different than
saying I'm just GNA let go I don't give
a hoot I don't care I baloney if you're
feeling a wave of energy about it or
emotion about it you do care because the
emotion is evidence that it is impacting
you and so most people understand that
you should just let it go or you
shouldn't care but they don't know how
when you say let them a couple really
interesting things happen number one you
acknowledge what's happening which both
acknowledges that your friends are out
to lunch without you and it also
acknowledges that it bothers you and
when you say let them you're
acknowledging the situation and you're
almost saying I'm above it and I'm
permitting this because I see it
happening and then something really
interesting happens because you're no
longer all worked up about what they're
doing you are forced to look back at
yourself let them if if my friends are
going out to brunch and they didn't
invite me and it bothers me that much
and I'm just going to let them do it
instead of sitting here stewing about it
what do I need to take responsibility
for you're toxic yes probably or I
didn't I don't ever invite anybody
out or if I want more experiences with
my friends I should be the one
organizing everybody to go out to brunch
or
maybe my friends can just go out and I
don't have to always be included and it
doesn't have to mean anything and maybe
I've got work to do with therapy and so
what happens is as you start to use let
them to lower your expectations to stop
focusing on other people and what
they're doing it forces you to take
responsibility for what you want in your
life linked to that was this thing that
I found which people just loved when you
said it which was you should stay in
your peace and stay in your power yes
and it sounds somewhat correlated to
that very much so so when you start
using it you will notice how often you
get agitated
or frustrated by what other people are
doing and it's strangers in a coffee
shop it's your
relatives it's like I we were just in a
situation this uh here in here in the
states for Thanksgiving where we were
down visiting my parents and they're in
a place that's small so we had a place
that we had to rent so that we could all
kind of be together but it wasn't that
close and every time it was a moment
where it was are we going to their house
we going to our house
and somebody had an expectation about
where we should be normally the old Mel
would get hooked right into that person
i' just be like let
him that per the people in your life are
allowed to have their emotional
reactions and it's not your
responsibility to manage their emotional
reactions part of the reason why we get
hooked into these toxic Dynamics with
people because you're part of the
dynamic somebody does something that
triggers you you go right in in you
start to change how you show up you
start to compensate you start to people
please or you get all mad and angry and
next thing you know it erupts and it's
the same thing over and over and over
again and you wonder why it never
changes well part of the reason why is
that person's never going to change you
cannot control that but you can change
the energy you're putting into the
dynamic when you were asked what was the
worst advice you ever given do you
remember what you said I do not what is
it you said the worst advice I was I've
ever received is that someone else can
make you happy oh it's so true it's so
true money can't make you happy someone
else can't make you happy and it's
correlated to what you were just saying
there in a way it's very correlated
because a lot of us are putting our
energy into trying to push other people
to show up a certain
way when if you were to pull all that
energy
back and conserve it for
yourself you suddenly start taking
responsibility and you have more energy
to take the steps and to change the way
that you think so that you can have what
you want in your life and there are
exceptions look you're not just going to
let somebody get behind the wheel of a
car if they've been drinking so if it's
dangerous if it's self-destructive is if
it's discriminatory you have to step in
in my opinion and do something but
here's the
rub hold the intervention with your
friend who is an addict offer to pay for
the treatment Center if you can afford
to do so but then you have to let them
do what they're going to
do it makes the responsibility of how
you show up entirely on you which means
you are now operating based on your
values and based on what you want in
your life and based on the kind of
person that you want to be not because
you're doing it out of obligation or
manipulation or that sort of
transactional nature that we get into
with people it seems to be both selfish
and selfless at the same time in a way I
don't think it's selfish at all really I
actually think it's one of the most
generous things you could
do how is not controlling other people a
selfish thing to do I'm not saying I
don't care I'm saying I'm aware that you
are a independent human being with his
own feelings and his own life path and
his own values and expectations and when
I step in and try to fix everything for
you or change how you feel I actually
rob you of both the breakdowns that you
need I rob you of the responsibility
that you need to take and I don't own
the part of the equation in every
relationship every relationship has an
energetic exchange I do
something and now you are going to react
and are you going to react based on
what's align for you or are you going to
react as a way to try to change how I am
taking that hook out though feels like
it serves you in a profound way as well
which is the self selfish part of the
equation doesn't feel selfish but over
the long term it's going to serve you so
it's it is a an act of self-preservation
or taking care of oneself yeah and I
also feel like there's a healthy dose of
curiosity in this because it's going to
reveal all the things in your life that
really bother you because right now
you're distracting Yourself by being
upset about other people in instead of
pulling that energy back in and going oh
well if it really bothers me that my
sister-in-law never comes to visit me
then I clearly care about this
relationship and so do I care about the
the them be me being right and them
always coming to me do I care about Tit
for Tat or do I actually just care about
building a good relationship with
somebody this is also extraordinarily
effective if you're dealing with
somebody that has any toxic tendencies
any narcissistic traits like when you
look at the research around especially
narcissism and the fact that people are
not born that way they're made that way
and it's highly unlikely that they're
changing based on the supply that they
constantly need when you go let them I'm
gonna see what's coming I'm going to
anticipate what's coming I'm going to
let them have their tantrum which is
what typically happens and
I'm going to go into to this wide open
I'm not going to allow myself to get
triggered by it because I am saying I
know who this person is I know what's
going to happen I've been in this
Dynamic for years and I'm going to let
them do what they do and when that
happens you also kind of pres it's
almost like a a emotional force field
that goes up does this apply to Chris
too oh hell yes I mean I um I'm trying
to think of um how is Chris we talked
about him a bit last time um Chris is
fantastic fantastic he's getting a
masters in transpersonal Psychology oh
wow and uh he I'm really really really
proud of him he has started the he he's
been doing men's Retreats uh for six
years and um why why was there a
catalyst yes um he came out of his uh
restaurant business a broken human uh
because the venture did not succe Ed and
he felt like an abject
failure and based on you know all the
messaging that men in particular get
about providing he felt like he had
completely failed his wife and his three
children and all the friends and
families that had
invested and as I scrambled and did
whatever I could to start try to keep us
afloat when things started to take off
for me the shadow that I cast just made
him feel even worse and so he was
looking for something that would allow
him to really reconnect with himself to
connect with other men and so he created
something called Soul degree and um it's
been a real passion project of his he
just does two or three Retreats a year
he just opened up next year's
registration and sold it out in 24 hours
which tells you a little bit about the
demand
and the desire for people to have deeper
experiences and deeper connection and
you know to kind of circle back on that
topic about goals if you want to go
there
um I think it's very important you know
every this time of year when January 1
rolls around January first is what's
called a temporal landmark and a
temporal Landmark I I'm not going to get
the definition right but it is this term
used for moments of significance moments
that create a before and an after and
we've all had experiences on birthdays
103y was one of them for yes of course
right a before and an after the reason
why there are more people that go to a
gym on the first of a month is not only
because of the uh incentive with pricing
but it's because it's a temporal
Landmark quarters in a business temporal
Landmark but January 1 is a really huge
tempor Al Landmark I think it's very
important to do an assessment or an
audit of where you are before you jump
into what's next and I think this is the
piece that everybody misses when they
sit down and they write out a list of
goals the most important part of setting
goals for yourself I believe is first
understanding where you are and there's
a simple exercise that you can
do it's sort of like um if you think
about directions it's mathematically
impossible to give somebody a set of
directions unless we know your starting
point and where you want to go and most
people pick their head up and go I want
to go there without going well where am
I right now and so just take out a blank
piece of paper and write out all the
categories of your life it there's no
formula for this literally you could do
10 different categories you could do
five you could do relationships money my
health my happiness and just rank them
where are you one to 10 one to five
whatever you want and explain
why and I think a really good goal is to
Simply say to
yourself how do I make this number two
or three points
higher that right there changes your
direction you know where you're starting
from and you ask yourself well if my
health is a two what would a five look
like and can I work towards that and to
me that's what goals are goals are that
sort of point on a map that are your
next couple steps dreams are something
else and dreams are just as important
because dreams
are that moment where you pick your head
up and you get really
quiet and you tune in to what your mind
body and spirit is telling you kind of
aim that inner
Compass out into the distance and you
ask yourself where do I want to
go like if you think about five or 10
years from now and and the easiest way
for me to figure out that is who am I
jealous of that usually shows up a lot
faster than who am I inspired by because
jealousy is just blocked desire you
can't can't feel jealous of somebody
unless you
authentically want something for real
that you think that they
have and the jealousy happens because
you have somewhere in your psyche told
yourself you can't have
it and that's why it comes up as
negative but I want you to consider if
you were to allow
yourself at this time of year or right
now after podcast to
just
span the world and ask yourself who am I
either inspired by or who am I jealous
of give yourself permission to do that
and then get curious well what is it
exactly because it might not be the
fancy cars or the things that you see it
might be a sense of Peace it might be
that they seem to have a great uh family
life it might be that they uh have a
very vibrant energy to them that there's
something behind the stuff on the
surface that really is aligned with what
is hardwired in you and pay attention to
that because those dreams are there for
a reason see I think that they are the
beacons out in the future that are
directional
signals just because you have this dream
doesn't mean you're G to get it the
dreams purpose in your life is to get
your head out of the sand and to look
out ahead and to point you in a
different
direction dreams dreams and
goals it's funny because as you were
saying that I was wondering what your
dreams and goals must be and it made me
think of this comment that I saw on our
last conversation last time you came on
the podcast it said dear Mel you've
touched me I've had a similar molesting
experience I came out after the
experience and I told my parents about
it but I didn't tell them for many many
many years because I thought I would be
blamed for it because that is how my
mother always treated me I can finally
totally relate to somebody in you I've
been living in fear all of my 71 years
of life fear Capital words controls me
to this
day now thanks to you I have the answers
I can now live the rest of my days
better I've spent my life trying to fix
me with you I have directions to follow
now so thank you
Mel thank you for sharing that
um I um you know one of the things that
is profound about the let them
theory is that if you're in a situation
where you're terrified of somebody's
reaction just tell yourself let
them let them have the reaction that
they're going to
have because if you allow the space for
your parents in that situation to have a
really horrible reaction you've
anticipated that it's coming and you've
also allowed them to be human
and you Empower yourself to then do what
you need to do for
yourself which is to say it out
loud and to tell the truth about what
happened to
you because it's not about your parents
reaction it's about you finding the
courage and making the decision and
taking the action to say this
happened and that's the beginning of
your life moving in a completely
different
direction because you know
fear is something that runs people's
lives it makes you avoid it makes you
shrink it makes you live in silence it
makes you deny what you're
feeling and too often the fear that we
feel the most is we're afraid of what
other people are going to say we're
afraid of other people's reactions let
them have it let them be human let them
do and I'm not saying let people treat
you
poorly what I'm here to tell you is that
when you take responsibility for your
truth and you take responsibility for
expressing it and then you take
responsibility for your
boundaries and you take responsibility
for your
healing you do have the possibility
of living the rest of your life in a
completely different
way as you know whoop are a sponsor of
this podcast which came about from me
being the biggest fan of their product
it's been an absolute game changer for
my sleep for my recovery and for my
overall well-being whoop is a wearable
device this thing on my wrist right here
if you're watching me that not only
tracks your health 247 but also guides
you to improve it it's probably the
perfect gift for the person who has
everything or is impossible to buy for
which is what my friends say to me
because it's the kind of gift that keeps
on giving offering realtime benefits for
their health and their Wellness forever
so if you're on the hunt for the perfect
present for a loved one or a team member
or even for you this festive season I
would highly highly recommend checking
out whoop and they very kindly offered
our community here under the D CEO a
special discount just for you but keep
this to yourself if you head over to
join. whoop.com
CEO you can get that discount let me
know who you get one for and how they
get on as you know because I've been
sent thousands of messages these
conversation cards sell out
exceptionally quick so here's the deal
I'm going to make with you if you join
the waiting list which is in the
description below you will get sent
access to buy these conversation cards
one hour before anybody else they're in
limited Supply so if you really do want
to get your hands on them please do add
your name to the waiting list in the
description below and you can find that
waiting list at Theon conversation
cards.com but I'll also include it in
the description below wherever you're
listening to this episode when did you
receive your diagnosis of
ADHD uh I was I think like
47 how did it change things well it was
amazing I absolutely amazing you were
recently diagnosed right yeah um so it
changed everything because um I
finally had an exp
explanation for something about the way
that my mind worked and the way that I
felt that made me for 47 years feel like
there was something defective about me
and I couldn't figure out what it
was and I was diagnosed the way that
most women that are adults are diagnosed
and it goes a little something like this
you have a kid
so my husband and I have three children
and um our youngest Oakley was this just
amazing kind of casserole of things and
one of the things that he was is that he
had a lot of trouble in school he just
we didn't even know that he couldn't
read I mean talk about being a parent
that asleep at the wheel we didn't find
out that he couldn't read Steven until
he was in the fourth grade and the
reason why we didn't know and the school
didn't know is because he had so
overcompensated in the classroom by
being so verbal first kid with the hand
up blah blah blah blah blah like talking
talking talking that
nobody knew that he was having trouble
and all of a sudden the math problems
get harder because they become word
problems all of a sudden reading
comprehension and you know not not to
mention the fact that he also had disg
graphia which basically means that it
looked like was writing with his feet I
mean his handwriting was so bad and I
was befuddled by this because he could
literally sit in front of the TV and
play video games for hours and have
hyperfocus and all this dexterity and so
I just thought oh he's acting out he
can't stand school so we have this great
teacher in the public school system who
says you really need to get him tested
and I wouldn't test him in the school
and luckily we were at a point where we
could afford to go get I think it's
called a uh like a graphic something
something it's like a long
word and sure enough the testing comes
back and the uh PhD neuros guy is like
yeah well he has profound dyslexia he
has profound disg graphia he has
executive functioning issues which is
basically the conductor or the secretary
in the brain sort of helping you stay
organized in a couple steps ahead he has
ADHD and as I'm reading through this
report I'm sitting in the pediatricians
office office stepen and I'm looking at
this report and I'm reading it and I
look up at his pediatrician who I had
become good friends with because we had
three kids in the practice at this point
I'm like
Mark do you
think maybe have I I have
ADHD and he puts his paper down Stephen
and he goes do I think you have ADHD of
course you have ADHD you are the most
ADHD person parent in my entire practice
I'm like what do you mean he's like Mel
you're brilliant and yet you never do
what you say you're going to do you will
leave here and tell me you're going to
call you never call back your kids go
years without coming in because you miss
all their Wellness appointments you
scramble every single year for the uh
physicals that your kids need and you
beg us to take it is Clockwork of course
you have ADHD and I look at him Stephen
and I'm like why didn't you tell me he
said because I'm not your doctor and so
I went and I got the testing Stephen and
turns out yes ADHD dyslexia same profile
as my son
and what was interesting about getting
the diagnosis because I didn't
understand what ADHD was I always
thought that ADHD is that you can't pay
attention same that's not what it is at
all and so
learning about what it is and learning
that boys and girls girls present
completely differently so there's an
entire generation of women I don't know
if you know this but there's an entire
generation of women called The Lost
Generation and what happened is when
they were studying ADHD I guess in the
late 60s and early 70s they only looked
at boys and so boys tend to show the
symptoms of ADHD around the age of seven
and it typically is around um the
hyperactivity or the inability to kind
of like focus and and control their body
movements girls on the other hand don't
sh start displaying symptoms until about
the age of 12 and the symptoms are very
different girls become um inattentive
but in a kind of daydreaming fashion
they become a little bit more
disorganized and they aim all of this
back at themselves and so as you become
kind of more Inward and you are
inattentive and you're disorganized and
you start to wonder what's wrong with
you and now plus the average age of
girls for puberty is right around then
too so all this other stuff is starting
to happen and hormones are starting to
change if you
don't get properly diagnosed and treated
and by treated I mean the whole array of
things that you can do whether you're
talking about medication or just the
different habits that you can have or
systems that you can develop to support
yourself if you don't get
properly tested and you don't address it
do you know what the number one thing
that happens you develop anxiety oh
really well of course because you're
sitting in a classroom and you can't get
yourself to focus and you're
disorganized and you start to feel this
sense of alarm that you're going to walk
into a test and you're not going to be
able to do it that you're going to yet
again open your locker and the stuff's
going to fly everywhere that yet again
you're going to forget your friend's
birthday or you're going to forget to do
this thing and so all of this anxiety
Rises to the surface so get this so they
call us The Lost Generation of women
because what do you suppose if we were
not diagnosed so I'm 55 if I'm in
elementary school in the late 70s and
the you know and and they've only
studied boys and so none of this is on
anybody's radar screen you now have a
generation women who are developing
anxiety at Big levels in high school and
college I was textbook and so we get
treated for the
anxiety and medicated for it without
addressing the underlying issue all
along which was undiagnosed ADHD so for
me it was
absolutely lifechanging and it was
lifechanging to understand that ADHD is
not about your inability to focus it is
about the fact and I'm sure you probably
have dug into this and you know this but
for you know anybody anytime I talk
about this the number of women that are
going to write in the number of dads
that will write in about their daughters
the number of people that say oh my God
I had anxiety in high school too and now
now I've been uh diagnosed with ADHD and
it was because of my kid going through
this and this is exactly my story it is
happening over and over and over again
and so here's what really also help me
Stephen and it's
this understanding that focus and the
ability to focus in appropriate ways
requires two different neural networks
in your
brain and you can think about it this
way if you think about you know the
prefrontal cortex this kind of part of
your brain really has the job of almost
being like a conductor of an orchestra
this is the best um example example that
I've heard in terms of what's happening
if you have
ADHD and what's happening is if you
think about an orchestra and and the
orchestra's warming up right it's
like and the drums are Ting ding ding
ding ding and people are shuffling in
their seats we know that sound right and
then all of a sudden the conductor's
like tip
tip and everybody's silent
right in order to conduct an orchestra
you got to be able to do two things at
once you got to be able
to lower the volume on the strings over
here and then you got to be able
to
amplify the focus on the percussion over
here and what happens when this part of
your brain is not switching properly is
you are like Mel Robbins in college and
I would be with my books
and I would be in the stacks at Bakery
library at Dartmouth College and I'd be
there because I'm going to study
right and my Orchestra conductor cannot
shush anything so the second I sit down
if I'm going to study I have to do two
things I have to be able to quiet all
the ambient noise I have to be able to
quiet all the signaling in my body so
that what I can amplify my attention on
what I'm reading when this part of your
brain doesn't work what ends up
happening or at least this is the way
that it's been explained to me is that I
can't focus on my books because I'm
paying attention to the fact that my
stomach is grumbling and I hear people
walking and then I'm looking around and
then I'm paying attention to the fact
that I have to go to the bathroom so
then I'm up then I'm walking around and
that is how I lived for a very very long
time do you think that's the survival
response what do you mean becoming very
aware of your
surroundings you know what I mean has
anyone ever researched whether or not
there is a link between trauma and ADHD
yes and Gabel mate I believe is the is
the one that's made a pretty pretty
compelling case to me that ADHD appears
to be linked to Childhood trauma which
is you I'm going to butcher this so
please forgive me everybody the case he
made to me was that when you have a
chaotic or traumatic or stress childhood
as a survival mechanism you learn to
tune out and that's that's that's
protective so if your parents are always
screaming in the house for example it
makes a lot of sense for you to learn to
tune out in that moment but also to know
when to tune in obsessively and maybe
that's the hyperfocus bit the bit that
he really stressed to me was that kids
that go through some kind of
interpretation of a stressful
environment at a young age or a
traumatic environment I'm more likely to
have ADHD because they've learned to
tune out in order to sort of conerve and
survive it's like my rough understanding
of it well it makes a lot of sense right
because um if you also have a really
chaotic environment it might not be safe
for you to tune out yeah and so you've
got to stay in that hypervigilant mode
which I think would fry the conductor in
your brain it does yeah because you're
both paying attention to the the
survival signals in your body at the
same time as the chaos in your house and
even if you're tuning out the parents
who are screaming at each other you are
still tuned into it because heaven
forbid it escalates yeah you got to know
yeah and so I think it makes perfect
sense honestly but it was just a
GameChanger and it was a GameChanger to
know kind of the distinction between
boys and girls and the link with anxiety
uh in terms of it developing uh in a
pronounced way for those of us that have
had this experience of having this as a
diagnosis learning it late in life and
then tracing it back and going oh my god
I've been treated for anxiety for all
these years when the real issue was this
attention issue and if you take gabber
mate's Theory which I think is probably
accurate dial it back even further and
it's probably some form of childhood
trauma that put a kink in the
wires menopause you talked about
menopause earlier yes do we have to I
mean Jesus okay why what do you want to
know wh why did you respond like that
you know because it's um it's really
confounding and it's confounding because
there's I don't even know if that's the
right word it's overwhelming everybody
my age is talking about it because what
happens is you start to lose control of
your body and um you're going through
all of these changes that you feel like
you are not in control of and so you
know I realize I look like a very lean
person and so the truth is that I am a
very lean person I have not changed my
habits in I don't know eight years I
have very very healthy habits because I
force myself to do things I don't feel
like doing
um and yet they're not working and my
body is expanding and brain fog is
increasing and I am like a furnace to
sleep next to at night and um all of
which is a function of the changing
levels of estrogen in my body and what's
very challenging about um dealing with
kind of hormone changes is that there's
so much conflicting advice out there and
to truly know what's going on in your
body you have to be drawing blood you
have to be looking at what's going on in
the in side that is extremely expensive
for most people it also is a big
maintenance issue it's a gigantic pain
in the ass and it doesn't feel like
anybody really has a good handle on this
and I think as a woman it's very
frustrating to know that women were not
even involved in uh medical research
until the late 80s and it's even more
frustrating to know and look I could be
wrong on this but we had an expert on
our show explain that they only use
postmenopausal women because they don't
want women's hormones to throw off the
results of the testing that they're
going through with medication and so it
just feels like a massive gray area for
more than half the population our entire
network from the brain through the
entire body is running on estrogen
there's new research around like just
stopping menopause altogether because
women's uh Health out women's um I'm I'm
you know I'm not a medical expert so I'm
trying to learn all this stuff to
educate myself do I take a pill do I put
a cream on do I have this little patch
do I sleep on a pad that makes me cold
so my husband won't like complain that
I'm sweating like through the sheets do
I do on bamboo [__] like it is
so overwhelming and then and you know
and I even feel my cheeks getting hot so
it could be a hot flash coming on I
don't know all I know is I'm drinking my
water and I'm taking my progesterone and
I'm doing my estrogen patch and now I've
tried the blood draws and everybody has
a different opinion is it your gut
health is it your estrogen health I
don't know I just know my body is
changing and some days I feel like a a a
a a pass a a maror that's being put out
to pasture and part of the issue is the
lifespan we have if you think about it
like our our life expectancy has way
eclipsed the fertility cycle of women
and so we now for most of us will have
another 30 or 40 years if we take care
of ourselves and that's a long time to
live a very vibrant and amazing life
which I believe that we can and to have
a body where your entire system needs
estrogen and yet your body is starting
to lose it and so that's part of the
reason why there's so much interesting
research going on around whether or not
the answer is to just keep us
menstrating so that we're naturally
producing this in our bodies so
interesting it's funny because I'm I'm
not going to go through menopause myself
well that would be interesting but
obviously you'll do manopause though
because you'll probably have a drop in
testosterone will uhhuh but but on the
subject of menopause I'm going to be
surrounded by women that are going to go
through
it [__] and Bloated and all the bees
so get ready and I want to I want to
make sure I understand that's why I'm so
curious about it but it's I crazy thing
is I only learned about it like a year
ago on this book wait you didn't know no
about menopause no well that that's true
you're a 30-year-old man why or 31 why
would you know about menopause I learned
from interviewing people on this podcast
and i' I became so fascinated by it
because people aren't talking about it
enough or at least they haven't
historically the conversation has has in
my VI has risen in cultural um
popularity over the last couple of years
but Well here here's my take on it
Stephen thank God it has yeah because if
you look at the fact that women were not
included in you know the medical
research until the late
80s and you realize that more than half
the
population are women and that menopause
and women's hormone Health was a chapter
in the
Obin uh
schooling and it is an enormous part of
how a women woman's body functions like
if we pull away all the skin and what
you see is all the wiring the fuel that
is really circulating through a woman's
body is estrogen and other hormones this
is again I am not a medical expert I am
just a woman who is trying desperately
to figure out how to make sense of an
extraordinarily important topic that
until recent years has not been looked
at with the scientific rigor that it
deserves and demands and that women
around the planet need and it has just
been kind of like an afterthought that
okay you're going to take some hormones
and then that'll be that you'll be
through it I mean most of the advice
that I got when I started to get the
thickening and the hot flashes started
to come and it's too much information
for me to talk about all the other uh
symptoms that you may feel when you go
through menopause is basically like well
you know it'll take about 10 years and
then you'll bounce back that is not
acceptable when it comes to how we can
care for and
Empower more than half of the people on
this planet and there it is exciting
though because I do believe that
somebody will figure this out soon that
there will be more research there
already are companies popping up all
over the place that are doing really
exciting stuff it's just kind of one of
these issues that's really confusing
because if you Google it or you listen
to an expert on the topic it really does
depend on your personal history because
if you've had any form of breast cancer
or or history of that in your family it
can be very dangerous or
life-threatening for you to take
hormones and so again I'm I I have a lot
to say about this because I'm in the
middle of it but I don't know a lot and
I think that's the thing that's
scary my last question before I go to
the book the hardest question that
people ask me and I've struggled with it
for a couple of years and I still
struggle with it now to be honest is
they ask me what's driving me and I
always I I pause because I don't want to
give a [__] answer like what I do I
really know at the core of me what's
driving me you talked about a lot of it
being subconscious I don't really know
and the other thing that people ask me
is what's your goal and because I think
I've got this sort
of predisposition now or this
perspective that I don't know I don't
know if there is a goal I I know that
you know there's this state of being
that I want to AR in every day this
feeling I want but is there a goal
because I've completed loads of my goals
and it wasn't
that so so I'm cautious about setting
any goals so I'm going to throw the
question at you what is your thanks a
lot what what is your goal is there a
goal is that a [__]
question um because I've read that quote
to you that's I mean someone can't have
more profound impact on another person's
life than that so I'm like you know you
did it you have the gazillion followers
you've climb the mountain you got the
car the money savings the kids are good
relationships in a great
place uh my goal is to enjoy it as much
as I can a good goal another goal is to
um to have a great relationship with my
kids and my
husband yeah I think um
having it's very fulfilling to have
um our adult
kids uh be such good friends I really
love that
why does that make you emotional um
because they're cool I mean I just you
know why it makes me emotional is
because
um I know they're choosing to spend time
with us and um I saw this thing on um I
it's it's floating around I'm sure you
saw it too about how um the amount of
time you spend with your parents just
declines over time it like literally
goes off a cliff and so I um just love
the time that I have with them because I
think they're all really interesting and
unique and
um I love that they choose to spend a
lot of time with
us we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest leaves a
question for the next guest not knowing
who they're going to leave it for this
is it about menopause can you imagine
well it might be it depends on your
answer the question left for you I love
how these are always the most difficult
questions my questions are a walk in the
park um what is the most difficult
challenge that you have
overcome i' I'd say
um there's some I I have a bazillion
answers to this like I wanted to say
getting out of bed every morning when I
don't feel like it because that
ability to feel resistance in your body
and get out of bed and face the day is
the SK
that you need for any change and I over
and I I face it every day and every way
I think the most difficult if you were
to measure it in
time challenge would
be rewiring my nervous system if that's
even possible technically that's
probably not a thing that you do but to
deprogram all of the
crap that was there and you can't get
rid of it entirely but to make the
Pathways in my body that used to be
driven by either trauma or fear or
anxiety that were so hardwired to make
those not be the
default and
to gain a level of
self-awareness and have the tools to be
able to catch myself and be like Oh not
going to be the grizzly bear right now
and focusing on being action orientated
you said yeah and
just prioritizing
peace well thank you thank you so much
for your um for your Brilliance oh I
could I could talk about so many
specific things that I think are so
exceptional about you but that would
probably be here for another two hours
or so so um thank you so much because
you you know you
um you have a wonderfully unique talent
wisdom ability to dissect understand and
reflect Express be authentic vulnerable
in a way that the world so desperately
needs it needs someone with that talent
for understanding introspection
processing communication and that's what
you have and I don't I it's hard to
think of many examples where I've seen
that like you are very much oneof a kind
and it's a and it's a responsibility
unfortunately it's a great
responsibility to I don't feel that way
I feel like it's so much easier than
Faking It D I look at you and I go
you've got so much talent that it's a
responsibility because you can impact
71y old you know lady here to Pivot her
life I give that's a responsibility and
you know what I think is a great thing
in life meaningful responsibilities I
think we're all trying to find it and I
think that's what you have the gift of
so um you know I'm always going to be
your number one fan and gosh I actually
just think you're at the beginning of
your journey so I'm excited to see all
of it play out thank you Mom thank you
can I say one more thing no I'm joking
of course you
can that comment by what was her name I
don't think she left her name she didn't
okay so that comment name for you that
that comment makes
me one of the reasons
why
I think I'm so driven is
because I know how many
people go through life day-to-day
feeling
invisible and stuck and not
seen and so if I can
share any small thing that I've done
that has made a difference or any
detail about a challenge that I'm facing
even if it's
complaining about menopause and hot
flashes and bloating
if that means one human being out there
somewhere across the world goes I'm not
the only
one that's why I do what I do because
I lived inside a body and a brain for
too many decades going I think I'm the
only one who feels this way I think
there's something wrong with me I don't
think I'm ever going to be able to fix
this and it's simply not true you're not
the only one there's somebody on this
planet going through it and has changed
your life for the better and if they've
done it so can
you thank you you're
[Music]
welcome as you'll know this podcast is
sponsored by
H and I have to say it's moments like
this in my life where I'm extremely busy
and I'm flying all over the place and
I'm recording TV shows and I'm recording
shows in America and here in in the UK
that hu is a necessity in my life I'm
someone that regardless of external
circumstances or professional demands
wants to stay healthy and nutritionally
complete and that's exactly where heel
fits in my life so if you're looking to
try heel for the first time and to get
into it and to join the huligan family
I'd highly recommend you try this
out do you need a podcast to listen to
next we've discovered that people who
liked this episode also tend to
absolutely love another recent episode
we've done so I've linked that episode
in the description below I know you'll
enjoy
[Music]
it